bonsoir les élections départementales se
dérouleront bien les 22 22 mars 22 et 29
mars après les vagues bleues marines des
municipales et des européennes depuis
l'entrée historique au sénat le fn
entend créer la surprise pour le parti
socialiste il faudra plutôt essayer de
limiter la casse comme on se positionne
l'ump le parti doit déjà en terminer
avec son élection interne pour la
présidence le 29 novembre nous en
parlerons tout à l'heure avec jean
françois raynal le secrétaire
départemental de l'ump pour le moment je
reçois benoît hamon bonsoir ancien
ministre délégué à l'économie sociale et
solidaire à la consommation ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale vous
avez récupéré votre poste de député fin
septembre jusqu'à présent c'est jean
philippe mallet votre suppléant qui
siégeait à l'assemblée pour représenter
la 11e circonscription des yvelines un
mois après votre arrivée au palais
bourbon où vous sentez comment plutôt à
l'aise après vos déclarations de la
semaine dernière vous avez vivement
critiqué l'exécutif oui à l'aise de bons
joueurs merci jean philippe mallet pour
le travail qu'il a fait comme suppléant
et pour représenter les habitants de la
circonscription
ça fait un travail extrêmement important
et je le remercie parce qu'on est au
reste évidemment extrêmement proche là
et l'autre lui sur le canton de bois
d'arcy et moi ce côté trappe elancourt
bas l'assemblée nationale le j ai fait
en quelque sorte une premiers pas parce
que j'avais directement intégré le
gouvernement le monde jean marc ayrault
plans de manuel valls et
y suis présent à la commission des
affaires étrangères ce qui m'a amené à
premier initiative
quasi-immédiatement demandant et en
proposant que le parlement français
l'assemblée nationale reconnaisse l'état
de palestine comme le parlement
britannique l'avait fait je pense que ce
serait un geste fort cette initiative
devrait trouver des débouchés dans les
jours qui viennent puisque l'assemblée
va décider si oui ou non elle retient le
principe de cette résolution mais si
elle le retient de la résolution sera
soumise au vote et pense j'espère qu'il
y aura une majorité
de parlementaires pour voter cette
proposition que j'ai faite alors ceci
étant dit je reviens tout même avec la
base de ma question c'est votre
sentiment au sein de cette assemblée vos
rapports avec vos collègues du parti
socialiste disait la semaine dernière
vous critiquer vivement à l'exécutif
c'était une menace pour la pour la
république n'est pas une position
forcément j'ai du théâtre je veux
préciser parce que c'est vrai que la
phrase sortie de son contexte elle et
elle donne l'impression d'une
part assez brutale les digère préciser
quel est le raisonnement que je
développe dire déjà depuis plusieurs
mois et que je développais ce qui était
très familial oreilles de mes anciens
collègues du gouvernement depuis
longtemps au gouvernement je pense que
on prend le risque si on a une politique
est une politique
exclusivement de réduction de la dépense
publique donc des capacités
d'intervention de la sécurité sociale
des capacités d'intervention de l'état
on prend le risque de diminuer ses
capacités d'intervention d'affaiblir la
république
en clair moins d'état moins d'état
social ses moindres et public c'est
l'histoire de la france est moins deux
républiques aujourd'hui c'est plus de
front national et il faudrait être
totalement aveugle ne pas nommer les
choses et nommer les choses aujourd'hui
c'est voir quoi et dire quoi c'est que
le front national élection après
élection est de plus en plus puissants
et s'approche non pas la conquête du
pouvoir local mais potentiellement de la
conquête du pouvoir national c'est ce
que j'ai voulu dire en disant attention
à ce que ces choix politiques la de
réduction de la dépense publique ne se
traduisent pas au bout du compte par le
fait que nous nourrissions
l'inquiétude des français leur
ras-le-bol le sentiment d'être de plus
en plus fragile abandonné et que ça les
amène à voter front national quand je
dis ça je m'adresse aussi à la droite
nous fait 50 milliards de réduction des
primes en place mais il faut juste
savoir que la droite propose 130
milliards du fonds dépenses publiques
vers quasiment trois fois plus que ce
qu'on propose vous imaginez ce qu'il
resterait de service public et au
passage voix des élus de droite qui
parfois juste titre s'inquiète de des
concours de l'état aux collectivités
locales je ne sais pas ce qu'on aurait
encore à donner comme dotations aux
collectivités locales si nous
appliquions leur mandat mais voilà ce
que j'ai dit bon après une interview du
premier ministre qui dit lui exprimer
une vision assez différente de la mienne
enfin le foll qui dit von rien quitter
le parti socialiste oui mais il faut
faire correctement son travail de
journaliste sur les dix a repris ses
droits après oui mais les maquis monde
mais qu'est ce qui compte ce qu'il a dit
mais aussi de le laver laver votre linge
sale en public et puis aujourd'hui avec
son pédalage non c'est pas être pédalage
c'est que c'est toujours délicat pour ce
moment on est dans cette situation
depuis chevènement il ya la phrase quand
on est au gouvernement
on ferme sa on démissionne et au moment
où moi j'ai choisi
j'ai choisi de ne pas rester au
gouvernement alors que le président de
la république me le demander
on me demande maintenant deux ans que je
suis en dehors de toujours ne pas
paralyser toujours des vous êtes dans
l'opposition est ce que les ti cats
frondeurs satis mais ni l'un ni l'autre
je suis socialiste j'ai été porte parole
du parti socialiste je reste membre du
parti socialiste pourquoi est-ce que je
suis attachée au mot socialiste d'abord
jolie muya social doit oser faire
société je trouve que c'est plutôt
positif et qu'il faut arrêter ces procès
en modernité ou un archaïsme déjà rocard
traité mitterrand d'archaïque
l'occurrence l'arrivée le contexte
politique vu la situation pour le parti
socialiste n'ait pas peur que ça
brouille aussi le message vis-à-vis des
électeurs ou de la désertion des
citoyens conserve le mans mais je vous
confirme on ne sait pas aujourd'hui le
parti socialiste et qui sait quoi faire
où il ya incontestablement mai mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est là parce
que honnêtement aujourd'hui que nous
disent nos électeurs avaient je vais
prendre ceux qui m'ont élu député sur ce
territoire il pourquoi dans ce que vous
dites est ce que vous faites vous êtes
si éloigné de ce que vous disiez vous
veniez faire en 2012 et c'est cela
d'abord qui nourrit le une sorte de
surprise d'étonnement et c'est à partir
de là et de ce décalage entre les
promesses ce pour quoi on est élu est ce
qu'on fait et d'autre part
et le gouvernement n'est pas seule
responsable
je veux le dire mais l'absence de
résultat des politiques économiques
mises en oeuvre au niveau européen
décliné en france quand j'ai dit
l'absence de résultats là encore nommer
les choses c'est dire quoi qui a quatre
cent cinquante mille chômeurs de plus
qui a plus d égalité je croisais tout à
l'heure une des responsables de la croix
rouge sur le territoire sur la
circonscription qui me dit quoi beaucoup
plus de monde aujourd'hui donc en clair
sur un territoire pourtant riche comme
le nôtre on se gargarise des entreprises
qui sont des formidables capacités de
d'innovation de recherche mais on a des
poches de pauvreté endémique et ses
proches ne se sont pas résorbée et bien
à partir de là l'absence de résultats la
crise qui se poursuit et le décalage
entre la promesse d'une politique et la
réalité d'une autre politique pour
laquelle nous n'avons pas été élus et
qui est mise en oeuvre cm le
gouvernement va pas changer de politique
pour autant malgré les appels que vous
pouvez leur lancée la loi vous voulez
faire entendre moi je pense nouvelle
valve qui dit j'ai un cap je me tiens je
fais les réformes qui sont pris à moi je
pense qu être pragmatique c'est regarder
la réalité en face et j'espère que cette
réalité amènera à ce qui est des
inflexions sinon à quoi ça sert de faire
de la politique si on ne peut pas
obtenir d'inflexion à ce moment là faut
se mettre faut rentrer dans l'armée se
met la douane le doigt sur la couture du
pantalon et obéir ce qui dans l'armée se
justifie pour ce qui est du débat
politique si le débat a lieu au ps comme
il a lieu en dehors du ps dont beaucoup
d'autres formations politiques
heureusement c'est parce qu'il allait
notamment la société oui mais est-ce
quelque chose à faire donc le bras de
fer va se pensent mais bon c'est pas
comprenez moi moi je ne tire aucun
plaisir à ce que ce débat ait lieu sur
la place publique parce que je sais que
cette l'impression qui va dominer c'est
une impression de confusion donc ça
affaiblit notre camp mais si jamais au
nom de ce principe là du coup il fallait
se taire ne rien dire et ne pas peser
pour ça change là je serai quoi rester
coupable d'un silence qui est un silence
kiki que mes électeurs me reprocherait
aussi donc on a le choix entre deux
mauvaises solutions je préfère parler
c'est contribué à infléchir la la
situation parce que
d'abord je vais vous dire parce que les
électeurs de ma circonscription ici me
le disent ils me le disent on
ne peut plus clairement on vous entend
bien parler de la circonscription de vos
électeurs vous revenez sur ce terrain de
saint quentin en yvelines sur cette 11e
circonscription pour vous y implanter
durablement la circonscription qui a
tout de même changé depuis les dernières
élections législatives à la droite dans
les différentes communes qui a progressé
votre adversaire d'ailleurs au dernier
scrutin législatif c'est jean michel
fourgous le maire d'elancourt manque pas
de le faire remarquer dit que si les
élections se dérouler demain ce serait
assez facile pour lui de récupérer votre
post comment vous allez reconquérir ce
territoire
parce que je serai rythme et si j'ai eu
la même considération envers notre
adversaire policière
qui me fait une publicité en marque
parce que ça relève de l'obsession mai
mais
ceci dit la grèce et 125 en sélection
depuis son obsession je parle des
chiffres c'est la droite a progressé oui
mais les scores bien maigre évidemment
il est
incontestablement progressé municipal je
le dis punk qui pourrait le nier et je
pense que les cantonales vont être en
national aussi d'ailleurs a progressé
sur la circonscription pour les raisons
que j'ai évoquées tout à l'heure après
si vous voulez bien ce qui se passera
dans deux ans et demi aux élections
législatives
on en reparlera nous allons reconquérir
ce territoire d'abord je vais par
conquérir un territoire pour l'instant
je suis député de la circonscription
donc je fais mon travail de député et je
vais le faire sur le terrain je vais me
déployés sur des enjeux très simple qui
qui aura obtenu que sur un dossier sur
le qui traîne depuis des années des
années la couverture de la nationale se
fasse sur trappe qu'on puisse demain
dans le cadre du contrat de plan
etat-région aménager le court et le
carrefour de la malle me donne tout sur
tous ces dossiers là nous aurons des
résultats et moi je ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que sur les grands chantiers
structurants toc dette dans le
commentaire ou dans la prophétie sur qui
va gagner dans deux ans et demi on se
consacre à essayer de 2,2 d'améliorer la
situation après
on verra qui sera candidate ump dans
deux ans et demi on verra qui sera
candidat du parti socialiste on pensait
pas en tout cas déjà c'est pas
d'actualité non je quand la nature non
parce que si je commence à penser à cela
dans deux ans et demi que je crois que
surtout je perdre le fil de ce qui est
l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est à dire
être un député qui vote les lois
représentent les électeurs de cette
circonscription est quelque chose en son
temps on va préciser parce que c'est
l'actualité aussi vous avez quitté votre
mandat du conseil régional aussi j'ai
choisi je devais quand on est
déterminés on a il fallait que je
choisisse autre conseiller régional
ile-de-france ou conseil municipal de
trappes et j'ai choisi de garder mon
mandat de conseiller municipal de
trappes aidé à bordeaux des mots comme
honda de kossi régional d'île de france
je vais faire une parenthèse pour faire
réagir sur un dossier qui occupe l
agglomération ces derniers jours qu'un
dossier économique c'est le dossier de
promo paul la pépinière d'entreprises
qui a été lancé par les anciennes
équipes de l'agglomération vous n'étiez
pas encore sur territoire c'est dans les
années 80 la nouvelle majorité de droite
ce qui arrive qui fait un audit elle
parle de mauvaise gestion cessation de
paiement aujourd'hui il ya des
accusations assez graves qui sont louise
surgit sienne majorité ont marre le
règlement même en justice quels sont les
éléments vous avez ça je pense qu'il ya
à partir de l'audit s'il ya une mauvaise
gestion je crois qu'il ya eu des
décisions qui avaient été prises
auparavant pour justement tiré les
conséquences et si elle est indiscutable
il faut tirer les conséquences
l'essentiel c'est quoi c'est qu'on
continue à avoir une pépinière
d'entreprises qui nous permettent
d'héberger de l'activité ici tu qu'on
puisse créer de l'activité sur le
territoire et on se penchera sur les
solutions que je sais que les élus
notamment les et du traspy travaille en
lien avec le président molié et je vais
vous dire
ma recommandation
à celles et ceux qui
parlent un peu vite c'est justement
d'éviter de se retrouver en situation de
dire tout et n'importe quoi juste pour
essayer
sur un tout petit peu de publicité sur
une chose viendra en son temps et et
ceux qui
voient là
non je cible pas ce chip ceux qui
parlent beaucoup et qui devrait
s'intéresser à la manière sans à faire
aujourd'hui et qui s'exprime le nouveau
président de promo paul par exemple non
nettoyés au conseil municipal de l'est
quelqu'un qui fait son travail qui est
conseil municipal de position mais je
leur reproche rien du tout nationale ce
coût est d'ailleurs il a raison de
travailler ce que je dit juste c'est que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui que l'essentiel
c'est qu'on travaille à skis et la
pépinière qu'elle promet paul
l'occurrence continue à fonctionner et
je peux vous assurer les choses c'est
que moi je travaillerai à trouver des
solutions puissent aller où siégeait
aussi à l'agglomération j'aime à votre
regard sur l'ouverture de
l'agglomération sur les futures
frontières de cette agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines il va falloir
dans le cadre d'une vaste réforme
s'agrandir jusqu'à huit cent mille
habitants on parle une extension du
territoire vers saclay sur versailles
également quel est votre positionnement
l'agglomération - opposition mais pas de
défendre
la grande communauté d'agglomération
huit cent mille habitants il me semble
que d'abord il ya des degré
d'intégration très différents entre
versailles grand parc la casse qui
la caps en essonne bref on à la capte
agglomération qui n'ont pas des degrés
dynamique d'intégration identique il me
semble qu'il faut qu'on recherche un
double objectif d'abord avoir une
communauté d'agglomération en capacité
de peser politiquement
dès lors que sur le yen l'état des
grands investissements à mettre en
oeuvre a affiché une volonté stratégique
d'aménagement il faut une agglomération
qui est la capacité à pouvoir être un
interlocuteur qui pèse de l'état mais en
même temps il faut que ça reste une
agglomération à taille humaine c'est à
dire qu'on puisse avoir suffisamment de
proximité pour pouvoir s'y retrouver
aujourd'hui le schéma tel qu'il est
proposé me semble être ne pas répondre à
ce double objectif c'est la raison pour
laquelle
j'écris j'ai écrit au préfet de région
pour le dire que ma faveur va davantage
à une agglomération qui parce qu'elle
a une cohérence sur le plan de la
recherche de l'université des transports
des bassins économiques réunir est la
caps du côté de l'essonne et la casse
qui comme une première étape et qui ont
peu et de nature à répondre aux grands
enjeux en termes de mobilité d'emplois
sur le territoire mais aussi nous
permettra de conserver
une
proximité avec les électeurs et les
citoyens de ce territoire
proximité qu'on perdrait si on faisait
un ensemble ils sont mille habitants à
mes yeux merci benoît monde est revenu
aujourd'hui sur le plateau de télé
filles pour cette suite politique une
toute dernière question revient ce soir
nationale vous ne quittez pas le ps
c'est pas d'actualité non non non pas
d'actualité je suis pas si ge réjouit
qui que ce soit aussi j'en attriste
d'autres mais non le parti socialiste
c'est mon parti c'est pas au moment où
il va mal qu'on le kitsch et même plutôt
l'impression qu'une majorité mais mme
immense majorité des militants
socialistes souhaitent que je reste et
que
longtemps merci députés donc de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines je reçois
présents jean françois raynal c'est le
conseil général des yvelines secrétaire
de l'ump dans le département nous allons
parler des prochaines élections
départementales
22 29 mars 2015 élections
départementales anciennement appelée
élections cantonales élections qui ne
déplace malheureusement pas les foules
et pourtant l'enjeu est important et il
nous faudra désigner celles et ceux qui
siégeront dans ces assemblées qui
interviennent notamment dans l'aide
sociale la voirie l'éducation avec les
collèges ou encore la culture et le
tourisme dans les yvelines à 21 cantons
pour 21 secteurs avant le découpage
opéré récemment il y en avait 39 39 pour
39 place maintenant il y en a 40 2
puisque nous allons voter pour un binôme
un homme et une femme devait être en
plateau avec nous ce soir jean françois
raynal le secrétaire départemental de
l'ump conseiller général des yvelines
sur le secteur de poissy nord il est
retenu par la circulation mais nous
sommes en ligne malgré tout avec lui
bonsoir jean françois raynal
bonsoir juste un mot pour vous faire
réagir tout de même même si vous n'avez
pas pu être là en plateau est sûre ces
nouvelles règles la mise en place de
binômes sur ce redécoupage également
quel est votre regard aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'est positif déjà pour
l'organisation pour la démocratie pour
le travail du conseil général
écoutez c'est une question qui renvoie à
la parité le législateur a souhaité
qu'il y ait une représentation au niveau
de l'assemblée départementale avec une
parité totale entre le nombre d'hommes
et de femmes pour y arriver ils ont eu
cette idée qui est quand même un peu
particulière je prends il y en a pas
beaucoup d'exemples dans le monde
d'avoir deux candidats si vous être élu
donc un binôme dans un scrutin qui n'est
plus ni nominale mais qui épie nominal
donc deux personnes qui représenteront
le même territoire et comme vous l'avez
dit dans votre présentation il ya une
heure et le nombre de territoires a
évolué que nous sommes passés de 39 ans
son agent clients quand on sait qu'il
fera quand même 42 g les investitures
concernant l ump qui doivent se décider
avant la fonte la fin du mois de
novembre normalement il ya des
discussions et forcément pas uniquement
en raison de la parité puisque on l'a
évoqué il ya aussi à moins de canton
certains ont fusionné sur votre secteur
par exemple poissy saint nom la bretèche
seulement deux postes pour quatre
sortants a priori vous et karl olive
resterait sur ce secteur est ce que
c'est déjà acquis ou en sont les
discussions
on va dire que à qui je ne suis pas dans
la mesure où bien évidemment les
investitures ne sont pas complètement
arrêtés vous l'avez indiqué cela se fera
avant la fin du mois de novembre
nous avons un comité départemental qui
est notre instance interne pour valider
ces investitures aux candidats qui
seront en lice donc mais on souhaitait
être candidat je vous interromps mais
vous souhaitez être candidat je souhaite
être candidat
s'était arrêté indique qu'il souhaite
aussi que je puisse faire partie des
conseillers généraux pourront apporter
de l'expérience dans une assemblée où
avec les règles que l'on vient d'évoquer
sera considérablement renouvelée sur les
40 élus presque les deux tiers seront de
nouveaux élus donc il est peut-être bien
qu'il y ait aussi des élus s'y
connaissent je dirais le fonctionnement
général est-ce que la discussion
actuellement est difficile au sein de
l'ump pour mettre d'accord tous les
candidats et ceux qui vont devoir malgré
tout laissé leur poste parce que il y
aura moins de canton et puis il ya cette
parité aussi parce que d'être bien ils
céderont pas
discussion n'est pas difficile parce que
il n'ya effectivement moins de
territoire il y a aussi des élus qui ne
souhaitent pas repartir donc il y a peu
de figures compliqué et puis il y à
aussi c'est pour ça que nous parlons
d'investiture la nécessité de travailler
avec nos amis notamment de vue d y pour
voir comment nous pourrions imaginer des
candidatures à la fois soutenu par l'ump
et par lui dei dès le premier tour parce
que les objectifs sont de pouvoir
remporter bien évidemment quand on est
dans une formation politique est le
responsable que je suis l'objectif est
de remporter le plus grand nombre de
cantons sans doute de savoir que les
adversaires politiques qui représente la
gauche ne sont peut-être pas au mieux
mais il faut se méfier haussier deux
victoires possibles et je ne le souhaite
pas de candidat du front national si
nous sommes tous unis et il y ait des
combats kenner entre plutôt la droite et
le centre et la gauche
il n'y aura pas ce risque sinon
vous appelez d'ores et déjà à l'unité
pour éviter au front national de
remporter l certains cantons de siéger
ensuite au conseil départemental est
justement une dernière question par
rapport à ça sur le secteur de pierre
bédier donc mantes-la-jolie mantes la
ville c'est l'actuel président ump du
conseil général il va se représenter sur
ce secteur là il y aura a priori à face
à lui le frontiste cyril note est ce que
c'est un autre étude pour vous
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas une inquiétude
parce que j'ai toute confiance dans la
capacité de faire campagne
elle devient vite et que l'on connaît
qui avait été le président du conseil
général donc je ne suis pas inquiet mais
nous sommes attentifs et je la connais
ce canton et on pourrait en prendre
quelques autres sont vraiment la
nécessité de faire véritable union qu'il
n'y ait pas d'ambiguïté je pense que
dans le contexte qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui n'ajoutons pas de la
complexité à une situation politique qui
est malgré tout compliquer merci jean
françois hénin d'avoir été malgré tout
en ligne ce soir avec nous pour le 7-8
politique de 7,8 à bout
on vous invitera sur une prochaine
émission et nous aurons à l'occasion
aussi d'inviter bien sûr les autres
représentants des formations politiques
socialistes front national qui ont été
évoqués entre autres le 7-8 politique va
maintenant se refermer je vous
retrouverai le mois prochain et puis
aussi dès le 2 novembre toujours sur
cette antenne pour café politique je
recevrai elle jean michel fourgous le
maire d'elancourt premier vice-président
à de saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge
de l'économie depuis le bistrot du
théâtre à montigny-le-bretonneux il sera
question de son parcours de son ambition
et des dossiers importants sur sa ville
sur l'agglomération notamment le ski
dôme qui doit voir le jour du côté de la
clé de saint pierre entre la nationale
10 et la nationale 12 et puis je vous
retrouve bien évidemment du lundi au
vendredi à 18h pour une pour le journal
l'actualité complète du département des
yvelines de notre secteur de
saint-quentin versailles très bonne
soirée